Glass shatters, a D-Class screams, the shrill
cry of the alarm sounds.
There's been a containment breach at the SCP
Foundation!
Somehow, The Plague Doctor has escaped his
cell, and is making a break for it!
Against all odds, he finds the exit, and he's
out!
He's free, he's on the lam!
But how long can he elude the Foundation's
attempts to track him down, and recontain
him at any cost?
It will take all of his cunning, his intellect,
and his strange anomalous abilities, but he's
going to try and hold onto his newfound freedom
as tightly as he can.
I'm getting ahead of myself here, though.
Let's start at the beginning.
Day 1.
SCP-049, or The Plague Doctor, may be an esoteric
anomaly whose grasp of medicine is practically
Medieval, but he's still a doctor!
He didn't get this far by not paying attention
to his surroundings.
So, when an unexpected power outage, triggered
by an experiment gone wrong somewhere in the
bowels of Site-19, gave him the chance to
escape captivity?
He took it.
The Foundation had recently revoked his access
to live experimental subjects again, and he
had had enough.
It was time to seize the moment and make a
mad dash for freedom.
With the security system down, the Doctor
broke open the door to his cell, grabbed his
trusty apothecary bag, and ran into the hall.
Guards were already swarming, ready to drag
him back into captivity, but he had planned
ahead.
Swiftly, he uncorked a glass bottle of silvery
liquid, spilling it onto the floor, where
it began to eat away at the tile, the shoes
of the guards, and, if they maintained contact
for too long, the soles of their feet.
This bought him just enough time to keep running.
The sounds of screaming down another hall,
and the raucous laughter of one Dr. Jack Bright,
signaled to the Doctor that most of the Foundation
staff were otherwise occupied.
With this in mind, he sprinted on, letting
his chitinous body carry him to the exit.
Then, for the first time in far too long,
fresh air on his beak, the sun in his eyes,
the scent of cut grass and damp leaves from
last night's rain.
The world was here, waiting for him just as
he had left it.
Of course, the world was still very much in
danger.
He hadn't just broken free for himself, but
to address the Pestilence head on as best
he could.
But for now, as he heard the sound of the
alarm, the guards gaining on him, he had to
prioritize his own safety first.
He had to hide.
Day 2.
He ran for ages, he couldn't be quite sure
how long as he had no way to measure the passage
of time except the position of the sun in
the sky.
It set, it rose, bathing the countryside in
soft yellow light, and set again, plunging
the land into darkness, all while he continued
to run.
Then, finally, the Plague Doctor stopped.
He had found a farm.
There was a little farmhouse, but he did not
dare disturb the sleeping family and alarm
them.
Instead, he turned to the barn for shelter.
He let himself in, tiptoed past the horses
as they slept there, and made himself a bed
from straw and a burlap sack.
From his bag, he pulled a pillow, and a little
spray bottle.
He misted the pillow with a lavender scented
oil, and finally allowed himself a moment
to rest.
He did not need to sleep like ordinary men,
but after such a long journey, he could get
pretty close.
Day 3.
The morning of the Plague Doctor's third day
of freedom began with the high-pitched whinny
of a terrified horse, and the frantic stamping
of hooves.
The Doctor opened his eyes to the sight of
one of the horses, now awake and not at all
happy to see a stranger in its barn, making
its fear and displeasure known.
"Buttercup?"
A man called from outside the barn.
"That you, girl?
What's got you spooked?"
The door to the barn creaked open, and before
the Doctor could do anything, he was face
to face with the farmer who owned the land.
"Who are you and what are you doing in my
barn?"
The man demanded.
"Good sir, I apologize for the intrusion!
I am but a humble traveler, seeking shelter-"
"You need to get out of here and stop scaring
my horses, now!
Don't make me come back with my shotgun."
"No need for that sort of thing!
I will be on my way!"
The Doctor collected his things, and, deciding
to spare the old farmer rather than using
more extreme methods to change his mind, left
the barn in a hurry.
Day 4.
With the farm far behind him, the Plague Doctor
trudged along on his journey, always keeping
an eye out for unmarked vans and armed guards.
So far, though, he was safe.
He hadn't had a spare moment to return to
his experiments, though, which was beginning
to wear on him.
The work was what had motivated him to break
out in the first place, and now he wasn't
sure when he would be able to make time for
it.
Cruel irony indeed.
But then, as if his silent prayer had been
answered, he heard a peculiar sound coming
from the woods just off the dirt road he was
walking down.
A sickly bray, from an injured animal.
A poor soul in need.
A patient!
He followed the sound to its source: a deer
lay on its side, clearly sick or injured somehow.
"Do not be afraid, my friend."
The Doctor said softly.
"You are sick, but I can make you well."
He sat his bag down on the grass, and got
to work.
First, he touched the deer with a gloved hand,
stopping its heart and putting it out of its
misery.
Then, he reached into his bag for his trusty
tools and some of his best medicines.
In no time at all, the deer was reanimated,
cured, walking around again like new.
Sure, it was a little bit different, stumbling
a bit, and each eye looked in a different
direction, but the Doctor considered the treatment
a success.
A day well-spent!
Day 5
The next day, feeling reinvigorated after
his successful encounter with the deer, the
Plague Doctor began his quest for shelter
anew.
He walked most of the day, until, as the sun
was setting, he came upon something curious:
a house, dilapidated-looking, with a large
sign out front: "House of Horrors, Enter if
You Dare."
Though he didn't know it, the Doctor had stumbled
upon the local town's premiere seasonal haunted
house attraction.
To him, it was simply an empty house he could
take up residence inside.
He was curious, and a bit perplexed, as he
walked past plastic skeletons, animatronic
werewolves that popped out from behind styrofoam
tombstones, and giant fake spiders in cotton
cobwebs.
None of the fake monsters gave him trouble,
so, though he was confused by what he saw,
he continued to explore the house.
Then, he found something incredible: a laboratory.
There was a long stainless steel table, with
a mannequin strapped to it.
A row of prop surgical tools sat on a tray
next to the mannequin, and along a back shelf
were rows and rows of jars filled with liquids
that looked like something the Plague Doctor
himself would pull out of his bag.
He couldn't believe his eyes, after wandering
aimlessly for days he had found the perfect
place.
Almost as if it had been made just for him.
Of course, it wasn't, it was for the paying
customers who would be coming to the haunted
house the next day, along with the actors
hired to perform inside, but he didn't need
to know any of that yet.
He replaced the jars with his own, and the
tools with functioning ones.
With the exception of the plastic body on
the table, which he privately wished was a
real human subject, this was absolutely perfect.
Day 6, the haunt actors showed up for work,
and were surprised to find a new guy had beat
them there, and he was already in costume.
They shrugged it off, they were making minimum
wage and that wasn't enough to ask any questions.
They were there to suit up and get spooky,
and that was it.
They did appreciate his plague doctor costume,
though.
It was much higher-budget than anything they
had.
"Did you make that getup yourself?"
Asked a friendly zombie.
"Indeed, I did!"
The Doctor replied cheerfully, happy to finally
encounter a group of individuals who were
unafraid of him.
"Nice, bro!"
The zombie gave him a thumbs-up, and if the
Plague Doctor could have with his rigid beaked
face, he would have smiled.
These new colleagues were a bit unusual-looking,
with their ghostly white faces, vampire fangs,
green-tinged makeup and excess fur, but their
kindness was encouraging.
Meanwhile, the haunt actors were gossiping
amongst themselves, wondering where the new
plague doctor character came from.
Who approved it?
Who hired this guy?
Why was he doing that accent?
Whatever, he was plenty scary and a nice enough
guy to work with, so Frankenstein's Monster
let the Plague Doctor have the laboratory
set, and moved himself into the graveyard.
The customers loved him too, shrieking with
delight as he welcomed them into his laboratory,
asking if any of them would like to volunteer
to be a test subject.
Lucky for them, they had already been warned
not to touch any of the "actors" while walking
through the attraction.
As his first night at his unintentional job
came to a close, the Plague Doctor's new friends
bid him farewell.
"We're going to a bar up the road for a couple
drinks!"
The ghostly bridge said.
"Wanna come?"
"Ah, no time for revelry!"
The Plague Doctor replied.
"I must attend to my work.
Take care!"
The woman just laughed.
"Okay, see you later."
And so the Plague Doctor spent his night in
the haunted house again, tinkering with his
tools and his tissue samples, listening to
the royalty-free scary music tape play again
and again on repeat, into the night.
Day 7.
The next day, attendance at the haunted house
was slow.
The actors, with little to do, spent their
time scrolling aimlessly on their phones,
filming joke videos for social media, and
pranking each other.
One of them got the bright idea to pull a
prank on the new hire, the stranger that none
of them knew much about.
He would have a friend, turn out the lights
in the laboratory, and when the lights were
turned back on, he would have replaced the
mannequin on the table.
He couldn't have known what would happen.
All he wanted to do was startle the new guy,
freak him out with the sight of an unexpected
werewolf on his operating table.
And it was effective- sort of.
The Plague Doctor froze in place when the
lights went out, calling, "Hello?
What is happening?"
and when the room was illuminated once more,
he took in the sight of the living being on
the operating table.
"My friend!
You have come to me for treatment?"
The werewolf started to get up, disappointed
he hadn't managed to elicit a scream, but
the Plague Doctor reached out a hand to stop
him, and that was curtains for that particular
actor.
As soon as the Plague Doctor's gloved hand
made contact with the man in the werewolf
costume, his heart stopped.
"Oh dear."
The Plague Doctor remarked.
"Do not fear, I have the cure.
You'll be alright in no time at all"
By the time the rest of the actors came to
see what had happened to the werewolf, there
was a real zombie in the haunted house.
Then, it was pure chaos.
Actors running and screaming, knocking over
props and abandoning their seasonal gig, darting
between customers as they went, shrieking
"Don't go in there!
It's real!"
Naturally, this only made them want to check
it out even more.
But by the time they got inside, there was
no sign of the Plague Doctor.
Only one very lost zombie in a werewolf costume,
a few jars broken in all the chaos, and footsteps
in the dry grass outside, leading out of town.
Days 8 to 18
The Plague Doctor spent all of his eighth
day on the run walking, once more.
He was starting to get used to this, the endless
drudgery of the path to freedom.
He hated to admit it, but he was almost starting
to miss his cell back at the Foundation, the
routine of it, the quiet time to work, the
three meals given to him each day even though
he didn't need to eat to survive.
He missed food and drink, the simple pleasures
of bread, meat, cheese, fruit.
A mug of tea, a cup of wine.
He sighed to himself, wistfully.
Then, he caught a whiff of something lovely.
He lifted his beak, taking another deep breath.
The unmistakable scent of roast pheasant,
hearty and warm.
Beneath it, something else.
Mulled wine, spiced and inviting.
Smells that reminded him of home, of days
long lost.
He couldn't be certain where it would lead,
or if there would be a seat for him at the
table, but he couldn't resist following the
heavenly aroma to its source.
As he drew closer to the smell of food and
merriment, he could hear music.
The plucking of a lyre, the high trill of
a flute, singing and clapping.
Then, he finally spotted it.
Rows of colorful tents, long banquet tables,
minstrels wandering about and playing ballads
to anyone who would listen.
Men, women, and children frolicking in elaborate
costumes, plate armor, robes, gowns, and more.
Though the Plague Doctor didn't know how to
describe what he was seeing, he had wandered
onto the site of one of the state's largest
Renaissance Faires.
It just so happened to be opening day, and
he was just in time for the celebratory feast.
"Good day, Doctor!"
A nobleman tipped his hat to SCP-049.
"Are you speaking to me?"
The Plague Doctor was taken aback by the recognition.
"Why of course, you're the only doctor I see!
Her Majesty the Queen thanks you for your
service, for keeping us all safe from the
great plague!"
The Plague Doctor had no idea that this man
was an actor, playing along with him in what
he assumed was a scene for the tourists.
Instead, he took the words to heart, swelling
with pride and gratitude for the recognition.
"Good sir, it is my duty and my honor."
The Plague Doctor nodded politely.
Luckily for him, and unbeknownst to the rest
of the cast of players at the Faire, the man
originally hired to play the town Plague Doctor
had booked a commercial role that morning
and had decided not to go in to work.
That man's choice not to call and let anyone
know, though rude, led to a fortuitous misunderstanding
for SCP-049.
"Please, join us at the Royal Table!"
The nobleman made a sweeping gesture with
his arm, inviting the doctor to sit and dine
with him and the rest of the actors playing
members of the court.
"Thank you for your kindness."
If he could, the Plague Doctor would have
smiled.
He dined to his heart's content that afternoon,
listening to sounds of music and laughter.
He slotted into his role at the Faire even
better than his position at the Haunted House.
He answered questions from tourists about
his work as a physician, warned them of the
dangers of the Great Pestilence, and posed
for the occasional photograph.
He spent a wonderful ten days living in a
stylized, artificial version of the past,
basking in the warm glow of camaraderie - though
the other actors wondered why he never took
his mask off, even to eat.
Then, sadly, it was time for the Faire to
pack up for the season.
The Plague Doctor bid his new friends farewell,
and declined their offers to exchange numbers
and keep in touch.
He would, however, always remember them fondly.
Days 19-41
As he was departing the Faire grounds, the
Doctor caught a glimpse of strange men approaching
some of the actors, showing federal badges
and asking them questions.
He couldn't be certain that it was the Foundation,
but it was more than enough to make him cautious.
He would have to retreat into the woods once
more, and stay out of sight.
He laid low for quite some time, for 22 days
to be exact, but then, on Day 41…
Day 41 to 52.
It started to snow.
White blanketed the forest floor, soft and
cold.
The weather wouldn't kill him, of course,
but it was uncomfortable.
He would need to find some more efficient
shelter, to escape from the elements before
the winter storm worsened.
He trudged through the snow, into a new town,
small and quaint.
There was an abandoned church at the edge
of the main road, a bit broken down, but the
roof held firm against the onslaught of ice
and wind, so the Plague Doctor made it his
new home for the next 12 days, working quietly
and staying out of sight.
Day 53 to 57.
On the eve of the Plague Doctor's 53rd day
on the run from the SCP Foundation, he was
stirred from his work by the sound of a choir
of beautiful voices outside.
He looked, to find a group of Christmas Carolers
singing together, the rows of houses along
the streets covered in colorful lights and
glittering decorations.
Wanting to get a little closer to the music,
the Doctor left his hiding spot for the first
time in nearly two weeks.
But as the choir saw a strangely shaped dark
shadow, emerging from the abandoned church,
they screamed and scattered in every direction.
One of them yelled something about "the Krampus"
as they went.
Frightened by the whole interaction, SCP-049
found himself a new spot, under a bridge.
It was cold, but isolated.
At least, it was for five days.
Day 58.
On day 58, a group of local teenagers, rowdy
and looking to make some trouble, spotted
the Plague Doctor squatting under the bridge.
They pelted him with snowballs, laughing.
Before he could do anything about it, fortunately
for the teens, they ran back to their car
and sped away.
Drenched in ice and cold water, miserable,
and irritated, the Plague Doctor searched
for another place to stay.
Day 59 to Day 84
The Plague Doctor was able to slip into another
relatively quiet building: the local community
theatre, which happened to be an old opera
house repurposed as the site of volunteer-run
musicals.
While the townsfolk began rehearsals for their
production of The Phantom of the Opera, the
Plague Doctor watched from above, hiding in
the shadows.
Every so often, the stagehand would catch
a glimpse of a cape, the silhouette of a face,
a pair of dark eyes, but no one believed her
when she tried to tell them that the Phantom
was real.
At least, until a handyman went up into the
rafters to install some lights, and saw the
Plague Doctor for himself.
Then, it was time for him to flee to a new
town.
DAY 85 TO DAY 89
On Day 85, the Plague Doctor climbed up onto
the roof of a dark house to avoid a particularly
aggressive dog, and let himself in through
the attic window.
The next morning, a little girl came up into
the attic in search of a lost toy, and found
him there.
He waited for her to scream, but she didn't.
She introduced herself as Abby, and asked
if he would like some cookies and milk.
He accepted her gracious offer, and the two
visited with each other for several days,
until Abby's parents asked who she was talking
to.
They didn't take it well when she answered,
"The bird man in the attic."
DAY 90
On Day 90, Abby's parents called the police,
who, having been warned to look out for a
man in a "bird mask," got in touch with their
contacts at the SCP Foundation.
Feeling the authorities closing in, SCP-049
took to the wilderness once more.
DAY 91 T0 DAY 99
Though the air was still painfully cold, The
Plague Doctor managed to set up camp, using
tools from his bag to build a fire and construct
a makeshift tent.
He stayed there for three days before intending
to move on and throw the Foundation off of
his trail, but he was slowed by the appearance
of a group of hikers, bundled up against the
Winter weather and exploring the woods.
Afraid he couldn't trust them, the Doctor
touched one, to convince him to leave.
The man fell to the ground, dead, and as his
companions ran away screaming, the Doctor
vowed to cure him.
Working against the inopportune conditions,
it took him five more days to reanimate the
hiker.
DAY 100
On Day 100 of his time on the lam, the Foundation
finally closed in.
The Plague Doctor was just stitching up a
large incision in his patient's chest, when
he heard the click of a gun behind him.
"Come with us peacefully, and we won't have
to sedate you," the officer said.
With a heavy sigh, the Plague Doctor held
up his hands, stepping back from his patient
just as its undead body sat up, blinking its
unseeing eyes.
"Very well.
I will go back.
To tell you the truth, gentlemen, this has
all been a bit too much trouble.
I could use the rest."
Now go check out "SCP-049 - the Plague Doctor
Captured" and "SCP-049 Cures SCP-096 of the
Pestilence?!"
for more of your favorite mysterious masked
Doctor!